today we're gonna do something very
special I'm very serious we're gonna
play a little game I like to call is
this a real place in Pennsylvania or
just some sections didn't know it was
gonna be a sexy quiz a real place in
Pennsylvania or just some sex words it's
pretty specific intercourse intercourse
really cuts here all the BS and it's
just like yeah our towns named after
people having sex like no this is a sex
word that's not a real place that's
probably not a town in Pennsylvania just
a sex word it's actually a time I don't
know if I got that right or wrong what
do they do in intercourse probably a lot
of holding hands I would imagine deep
hole what I wouldn't give to be from a
town named deep hole people deep hole
deep hole deep hole deep hole could
refer to your ear I'm gonna say to you
polar the places we hit you your belly
button that's probably not a city or
your anus so it's just a second it's not
even a sex word who says that deep hole
how deep the hole is it like a tourist
attraction there's something funny going
on there crotch great name for a place
very powerful aren't we all from crotch
Oh sex food sex word everybody's got one
who's gonna name a place crotch I knew
it okay nobody that's stupid if
Pennsylvania had a crotch it'd be right
around here it would be the closest
place in New Jersey
Oh climax Pennsylvania climax should be
the capital of Pennsylvania if you want
tourists to come then you gotta have
climax is your capital I feel like it
could be a town name okay I'm just gonna
say this as a sex word
be blazin Pennsylvania this why does
everyone in Pennsylvania so horny
everybody wants to come there boom
Bald Knob literally they name their town
shaved penis matching being from a place
named shaved penis are we pretty cool
happens both trying to want to throw up
just looking at that word I'm gonna like
hope that it's just a sex word because I
never ever ever want to go to Bald Knob
Pennsylvania if it exists Oh
Arkansas I'm talking about Pennsylvania
where the Arkansas come from I just
don't want anything to do with this I
don't want anything to do with this
anymore Big Beaver like they saw one big
beaver and they're like that's it that's
the name of our town out of Utah there's
plenty of house named after like animals
and things just be 50 beaver is
definitely a place yeah I'm gonna go
with Pennsylvania town yes nice I would
have a little bit of fun in that town
not gonna lie well today I learned that
there's a lot of weird towns in
Pennsylvania I learned that people have
dirty minds all right what a big beaver
is appeal from Pennsylvania damn you
guys have some kinky mofos
[Music]